Hey, good afternoon, Jack.
Hey, Anton, how are you?
Doing good. How about you?
You're doing well, thank you.
Alright, good to see you, I think, after a month.
Yeah, yeah, an interesting month, nonetheless.
Yeah.
Vaid, how's everything going on?
It going well?
Going well, business as usual.
Good, good to hear. How's Scout doing?
Just doing good.
Becca.
Back to normal, back.
Back at it, you know, no normal, yeah, normal stuff as usual, so no, no complaints or anything from my side, so...
Great to hear that. Yeah, we have put him on the special port where the ITBD has more monitoring and everything, you know. So, yeah, everything has been changed. His workstation, his seat, and everything. We completely replanned.
Ohh, really? OK.
Oh.
So, yeah, make sure there is no further issue or no scope for any evenness, so.
So, he he doesn't sit next to you anymore?
No, now he's in front of me when I'm here and sitting next to me.
Oh, in front of you.
Yeah, that's right.
Got it, got it, OK.
Yeah, no, but otherwise he's doing a really fantastic job, you know, when it comes to his ticket handles working ethics and everything, so few opens now over there, but yeah, he's fully aligned, you know, we're glad that everything is back to normal.
Yeah, yeah, so are we.
No, we we lost a we lost a tech couple, well, this week's his first week out, so we he went somewhere else, so we're down a man, you know, on the team and definitely thankful Scott was able to come back, otherwise we'd be in kind of a pickle, so to speak.
So...
Yeah, I agree. Yeah, and apologize for little that delay. We was trying to get him on work on as soon as possible to fixing that, but it took longer than that. We're not expecting, you know, for, but I think he was out for almost.
Yeah.
Oh, yeah, it's fine. I mean, it was only a week, a week and a half, I guess, almost two weeks, I guess, but yeah, it's fine.
Two weeks.
And I haven't been, yeah, different stakeholder from different level involved, then yeah, so it'll become different, difficult to come on a final decision, you know, what to do, how to proceed. But at least we're glad that everything on track. Yeah, I think glad to hear that everything is on track. So I think we can jump.
We, we survived.
Right.
to our agenda, let me share my screen then.
Okay.
Right, cool. So yeah, again, welcome to our monthly business review. So I think he was out due to that issues for two week almost. So I have captured the data for the March and the entire April month. Yeah, there's no changes in the agenda. Everything remains same.
Mmh.
Right.
These were the few highlights for the last month. The daily board review, which I'm connecting with him twice a day, reviewing his ticket, what all he's doing, you know, kind of keep eyes, everything is on track. And his billabels, ticket resolution have been increased, everything is on track.
Thank you so much for filling out the C set for him for a month of March, and Scott has been Scott PC has been fully secured and the your PTS tool has been installed to enhance overall security and the protection.
Yeah.
These were the action items, so I think the, yeah, we can probably discuss about the SAP that we created for him a couple of months back that was in progress. We used to been supposed to connect last month, but due to that incident, we postponed that SAP to this month, so wanna just take your.
Final call on that, whatever we discuss, we are aligned with that or anything that you think still we need to work on or we need anything.
No, I mean, I think it was handled.
Yeah.
Appropriately, everyone took the necessary steps to make sure, you know, not only his PC is secure, but our data, you know, is secured as well, so...
That's right. Oh, security.
Security is important for everyone.
Yeah, security. Yeah, yeah, important. Very important. You know, yeah, exactly. Luckily there wasn't.
for us, for our client, for our engineer, yeah.
Any fallout from it, at least nothing too seriously right.
Yeah.
You know, we we were able to kind of...
Take care of the the one issue that was was out there, you know, the VPN.
No.
Information for one of our bigger clients, we were able to kind of get that get that change with no repercussions, thankfully, on that, so.
Yeah, and yeah, so, and also we just been, because he is already aware since he is very old in the system and with IT by design, but we put him for for week ITBD compliance training, right? So he went through that training to make sure he's aligned, you know, everything, so that part we completed.
Kour.
Alright.
while he was not working on the bench for almost 2 weeks. So he completed that training as well.
All right.
Right, so we'll talk about is the performance. So the data he had just for three weeks. So talk about March 30th till April 3rd. So we're going to stick to the 80% of the target that we have defined with him. So he was able to deliver 79% April 20th.
Two week was out, so 20th till 24, 81%, then 27th to May 1st last week was 73%. So overall he stand at 78%.
Okay.
Yeah, so he's involved in different complex desktop ticket and escalated ticket and the other things that he's contributing on the other side too. Anything on your side, anything that you observe apart from the number that we have?
No, I mean, with our team being kind of down one person, at least right now, you know, everyone's really going to have to, especially the tier 3 engineers, they may have to kind of step in and perform some tier 2 tasks or tickets, you know, work tickets to kind of help the team overall to make sure we're still maintaining efficiency, maintaining, you know,
The.
Timely resolution for all of our customer incidents, so...
No.
I agree with that. Let's move for his ticket closure count. So we that was for party, but we have to just at least 6 to 8 ticket. He should be closing in a day. So overall he closed 67 ticket, you know, which include his desktop, other escalation ticket in.
Yeah.
Everything, yeah, but hope the number going to be increased. You know, one person is already less, so he's gonna get more tickets or more billable hours on the that side.
Oh yeah, he should now. We should see that go up, so...
Yeah, cool. Right, so I think CSAT we already discussed, so thank you so much for filling. I think one thing which I appreciate if you just put kind of comment on that, you know, when you fill that survey. So what do we do normally when any CSAT that we get for the engineers? We have like the company call every week, right? That's where the entire company employee joined that call, we...
Mhm.
Share those feedback, you know, that that's what Scout get from the client. This would really fantastic job that is doing so, which really motivate him.
Okay.
Okay, yeah.
Right, so I think we already discussed this in our every call, so nothing changed. Yeah, I think that's what we have for today. And for the SAP, probably, yeah, yeah, go ahead please.
Okay, any, sorry, sorry, Anderson, any...
PTO days off that are scheduled for him. Holidays coming up, nothing. Okay.
No, not as of now.
The only the holiday which is coming on, I think, 20th, 25th on Memorial Day.
Oh yeah, for us, yeah, yeah, for us, yeah.
Upcoming. Yeah, that's right. That's only one. They still have in case if there will be probably 15, 20 days will be in the advance. I'll update you. But as of now, no, there is no one.
Okay.
Alright.
Okay, I still have them, just real quick, I still have them down for October 20th and...
Right, I think, uh, yeah.
Yeah, that's right. The...
November 24th.
Yeah, the festival, Diwali, yeah, that's right.
Okay, okay, alright, cool.
No, but in guess if there will be any, I will definitely let you know in advance on 20 days, 15 days advance, you know. But as of now, there's no plan. And for the SAP, we'll probably get the survey. That's separate from what you already filled. That's for just for the SAP program that we designed, how far we made the progress, how was overall. So you just fill that.
Okay.
the survey, then probably I can proceed with the closure of the SAP in place. So we are good.
Alright, yeah, go ahead and just send me that whatever, so...
Right, and again, if you find anything, you notice anything, we don't need to wait for our monthly call to happen. We're active on team, just ping me, I'll be there. Or maybe any other support that you needed from my side.
I will do, I appreciate it.
Thank you. Enjoy the rest of Jack then. Take care. Bye. Bye.
All right. Yeah, you as well. Take care. Bye-bye.